there are some battles you can't win
just ask the British army
no I'm not talking about Iraq or
Afghanistan in even the first war I'm
talking about the fight to win over the
hearts and minds of each and every
citizen of diverse old Blighty Black
History Month has kicked off in the UK
this week and the British Army
determined to keep its finger on the
pulse has dedicated the next 30 days
not just to black people but to all the
Asians who have served in its ranks
still haven't got over that colonial
guilt then we missed a trick here we
didn't explain that Black History Month
has expanded to include the history of
Asian people and their contribution to
hence our recognition of our historic
partnership with the Indian Army but in
the mine field of political
hypersensitivity the initiative might
just be a flop it's been slammed by the
very communities it was supposed to
ingratiate itself with unless these
Asians are black I don't want to see it
to be honest there are 12 months in a
year black history months took up 1
months of the 12 but they wanted to be
black Asian and minority ethnic months
WTF pick another months and make that
Asian History Month I'm sure a lot of
agents will appreciate it come on don't
be stupid
it's blackity black history month one is
they even criticized the army for its
lack of manners for the move a very sore
point for the British so thank goodness
for the good old delete button because
the tweet in question was removed not
before it had fired up the haters of
course and even brought in the odd
lonely voice of support the contribution
of Sikh Hindu and Muslim communities
can't be ignored if they consider
themselves politically black than they
are I can't even pretend to know what
politically black is but I can tell you
what Black History Month is initiated by
our friends across the pond the u.s.
decided to give up a month every year
you know to repent for all those
centuries of slavery and segregation and
it's part of a growing trend of
affirmative action that might just be
backfiring take well shameless
but university for example turns out
it's got racial quotas to ensure a
diverse community something that didn't
go down too well with the group of Asian
Americans who filed a lawsuit saying
they were being penalized to date in
favor of their fellow black applicants
despite having far better entrance
scores and indeed multiple studies have
shown that if the university based its
admission process just on academic
factors what a bizarre notion Asians
would make up over 40% of Harvard's
classes that's more than twice its
current figures the courts conclusion
that Harvard has shown that its
admissions program serves its compelling
interest in diversity but some racial
categorizations are necessary to serve
that interest and while the court might
have backed Harvard this time it's
opened a can of worms on an increasingly
divisive issue affirmative action might
find that its heyday is over so there's
a huge amount of marketing executives of
all these sort of social media advisers
in you know in places like the British
Army so completely detached from reality
and detachment society and they've sort
of just started to use all these social
awareness kind of campaigns things like
Black History Month just for marketing
but in this entire social awareness kind
of you know progressive stuff should
probably be left to the people who are
actually experiencing racism probably
left to people of color people who are
actually out there on the street
experiencing these things rather than
you know overpaid marketing executives
who are sort of defining and sort of
deciding their what everything should be
I think that by providing a lower
standard for a certain race of people
and a higher standard for a different
race of people
certainly first of all creates a lot of
conflict between different races of
people that would not have existed
otherwise but I think it also
demotivates
certain people you know who probably
would have been more motivated to go out
and do so based off of their hard work
and aptitude which now they're not being
rewarded for and I think that it it
provides unfair advantages soon we're
going to run out of months and soon any
action one takes to boost one minority
will aggravate another you've got to
admit it's tough out there on the front
line of political correctness
you